and now I'm going to get to probably the
most asked question that I've been asked
um not just today not just yesterday not
just on this ask me anything and not
just on my Instagram in the last month
the question that I have been asked the
very most is
how has Andrews conversion to Islam
affected your Brotherhood how has it
affected your relationship is it going
to affect your relationship is it going
to be strange living in a household
um with two faiths are you going to
convert these are a bunch of questions
that have obviously come through and I'm
going to try to answer all of them
uh within the next few minutes
so
Andrew's initial
Point
um about Islam he was making many months
ago before he officially went loud with
his conversion I knew about his his
thoughts and you know the way his his
heart was leaning for a very long time
and Andrew made a very good point
a very strong point and his point about
Islam was this he said if you walk
around a Catholic country a country like
Italy and you insult Jesus Christ so if
you walk around England and you insult
Jesus Christ you could say offensive
things about him you could tell an
English person or an Italian here you go
say something bad about Jesus Christ or
your God here's some money will you do
that and people would do that largely as
a whole and also saying bad things about
you know Jesus Christ in their God
nobody would face any repercussions you
could walk around the street freely
saying these slanderous things which is
very rude and very impolite and nobody
would do anything about it however in
the Muslim world you see where I'm going
here
such a example is simply Unthinkable a
Muslim would never insult his own
Prophet he'd never insult his own God
and and that too if you were in a Muslim
country or even in the presence of
Muslim people and you were to insult
their God or their Prophet they would be
absolutely Furious someone might even
punch you in the face
and that's very fair enough but what
Andrew failed to mention
which is the point that I think I'm
going to raise right here is there are
people in the world who will punch you
in the face if you insult Jesus Christ
interview insult
um uh if you insult Jesus Christ or the
Virgin Mary or anything and those people
are
the Muslims now if you don't know
religion and you don't know religious
history very well then I guess you don't
know that one of the most profit and one
of the most important prophets in Islam
is Jesus Son of Mary as they refer to
him or Jesus Christ as us Christians
call them so this Dubai the Middle East
the United Arab Emirates the Muslim
world is a part of the world where you
could not walk around and freely insult
Jesus so I feel perfectly at home in the
Middle East and I feel perfectly at home
living with my brother who is now a
Muslim he's going to put a Quran up
above his title belts in the house I
have no problem with that book being in
my house I am very happy
um for my brother in the decision he
made I think that it's going to benefit
him uh in the long run I think that he's
a lot happier than I've seen him in a
very long time and good for him
bro I was not ready for that me neither
man organic bro alhamdulillah man I
haven't seen this video I'm assuming you
have another I have not no it's not a
lot I know bro when he said that I was
literally thinking that too in my mind I
was like he's like there's nobody that
would punch anyone if they I was like
bro I'm a Muslim I would do that I would
punch someone a bit but then he said it
I was like wow yes and you know even him
mentioning that Andrew Tate's been
happier his brother's been happier than
he's seen him before you know that's
beautiful that's what we talk about on
the channel that's what Islam does it
makes you content
um this is a side note
um but I've been thinking about it
recently you know people who look at
Andrew take who liked him before they
are basically attached to what Andrew
take calls Hedonism which is indulging
in self-pleasure and all of that stuff
and I think people are looking for
happiness and they're looking for the
wrong thing and what they should work
for is what Andrew Tate you know has
found which is contentment
contentment
um in in Allah in Islam in your religion
in your belief in who you are as a
creation of Allah and to hear his
brother describe him in that way of he's
happier now is very beautiful and um
100 I actually I felt I felt the same
thing when he was going on about you
know there are people who will punch you
in the face if you saw Jesus and it's
also the Muslims alhamdulillah we we
give
huge huge respect to the prophets and
The Messengers of Allah
and we make no distinction between them
I agree bro
and there's a I'm falling like obviously
just like you probably a lot of
different Muslim you know Instagram
pages and all that so I forgot which one
I saw that said this or like some
scholar someone but it said the heart of
a believer
um or the state of the heart of the
believer
finds Paradise before eventually finding
Paradise
and I think it's wonderful that you
mentioned the thing about contentment
because contentment is such a good word
to describe how you feel when you choose
to accept and submit to Allah after
Islam has been made clear as day which
it is bro let's be honest for even the
people that disbelieve or choose to
disbelieve they still know deep in their
hearts like there's a you know there's
these jokes these memes that people say
you know in Ramadan they're non-muslim
friends are reminding them oh don't eat
don't drink it's like they know
themselves you know and a lot of these
non-muslims know about things that we do
and we believe in that are correct and
things that we abstain from that are
wrong maybe they just haven't come to
terms with accepting Islam but they know
bro they know you know drinking is bad
for you
pmo is bad for you even if they they
don't have a Deen yet you know
yeah yeah
100 100
I um I think on a side note I think
there's there's probably a lot of
pressure that people are putting on on
Tristan to you know accept Islam become
Muslim as well
um and I think it's important to say let
the brother you know take his time as
well let him look into Islam and um let
him you know come on his own volition
once he he sees Islam is the truth and
like you mentioned bro it's not hard to
see Islam as a truth it's very clear
and Halal Haram these things are very
clear so when a person finds the truth
you know it's up to Allah to allow them
to accept it internalize it and to
really feel that contentment that Islam
brings you in life uh it's something
that you know no one the the king or the
president or the ruler or nobody you
know with everything in the world take
anyone who has everything in the world
they will not feel that level of
contentment I know it sounds silly but I
think there's a story of of two sahaba
where they were sitting um and they
basically only had dry bread to eat and
it was so dry they would dip it in the
ocean not even like a pail of water or
well in the ocean right to eat it
and they were saying if the if the Kings
and the rulers of Rome and Persia knew
the the basically the happiness the
contentment the the you know
blissfulness we feel in our hearts they
would send armies to come and try and
take it from us
um I don't know
I remember the first time you told me
that I was just like wow because I can
feel that within you know in my own life
in my own small things that I do like
for example just going to the Masjid you
know and just
you're outside you're like you know what
why not just pray at this motion instead
of going home and praying so I just you
know go and put my shoes there's no one
there bro and just just peaceful it's so
simple
you know you're not in a nice fancy car
you're not in a nice fancy house but you
have everything that matters in the
world bro yeah 100 bro very very
beautifully said and um you know it gets
people thinking you know people wonder
like why do I have to say Praise of God
why do I have to say you know
subhanallah why do I have to say God is
greater like why do I have to say these
things
um it doesn't benefit God right when I
say Allahu Akbar God is greater God
doesn't get greater than he is there's
no way that's possible because Allah is
Unlimited in his greatness he's the
highest above everything else
so why would we say something like
subhanallah and if you were to think
about some of the benefits you know you
could think about it being like positive
self-talk in a way but instead of
talking positively about yourself you're
reminding yourself about the greatest
being Allah
you know when you say subhanallah
praises to God
you're a man you're reminding yourself
of how praiseworthy Allah is
and you you stop and think wow that's
the that's the Lord I worship that's the
one I worship the one who's worthy of
worship when I say alhamdulillah you say
all thanks is to Allah
all right what do you think Allah for
everything literally every single thing
every second that you take a breath is a
mercy from Allah you know and when you
when you're thankful to Allah again side
note gratitude thankfulness is the is
the greatest motivator people think
anger is the greatest motivator like you
come to you go up to somebody like hey
you can't do it I know you can't do it
people think that that angry like oh I'm
gonna show you I could do it is the
greatest motivator it's not true
gratitude is the best motivator you're
actually motivating yourself to do
better for the sake of Allah you know
you say there's none worthy of worship
obedience anything except for Allah
you're reminding yourself the one you
serve that you're not gonna submit to
your desires for money for women or
whatever you're not going to compromise
your belief or your religion because
Allah is greater God is greater greater
than what greater than everything that
exists no matter what exists no matter
what you're looking at Allah is greater
than that thing you're scared the tribe
is Gonna Come attack you you're scared
of mob is going to come attack you it
doesn't matter Allah is greater than all
of them you know these things like a
person is Unstoppable Unstoppable when
they believe these things truly and
that's where that contentment comes from
that's why it's so hard to break Muslims
bro it's so hard to break the Muslims
because
like Andrew Tate
and uh inshallah I would love to see
that bro shall lay it up if you guys
made it this far we got a special
announcement for you guys this Friday
December 2nd 6 p.m Eastern Standard Time
Rami bro who are we going live with
we're going live with sunny Faz and his
mom and his mom yes and his mom is
Christian loving him oh my God bro
they're about to confront us about the
biggest Muslim stereotypes Islamic
stereotypes things they've been taught
they're going to ask us about
clarification they're gonna ask us about
why would we believe about what we
believe we're gonna ask them about why
they believe about what they believe
seek some common ground seek some
understanding and then insha Allah insha
Allah insha Allah
that they might actually accept our
invitation to Islam I'm not saying they
will but it's possible we gotta still do
our part right even Angel is gonna be
there bro I know anno's been gone for a
few days but even ano is going to be on
the stream make sure you guys check it
out Christian mom Sony me Rami anho what
could go wrong put that on your calendar
this Friday December 2nd at 6 PM EST 11
p.m UK time it's a live stream not
pre-recorded you can ask your questions
do your thing inshallah make sure you
guys come and tune in show your support
foreign